ونبقى مع الشان الايراني فالنظام هناك
يتجسس على هواتف وخدمه الانترنت لمواطنيه
لكن المفاجاه ان هذا الامر قد يكون حدث
بمساعده شركات اجنبيه تقرير لايران
انترناشونال يقول انه من الممكن ان تكون
شركات بورتفان الكنديه وتلس البريطانيه
وبروتي الروسيه تعاونت مع النظام في تنفيذ
نظام سيام لتتبع الهواتف المحموله
للمتظاهرين افاد التقرير بان صيامه هو
نظام يحتوي على قدرات تجسس خاصه تستهدف
شبكات الهاتف المحمول الايرانيه وباستخدام
هذه الاداه يمكن للنظام ابطاء او قطع
الانترنت عن الهواتف المحموله وكسر تشفير
المكالمات الهاتفيه وتتبع تحركات الافراد
او المجموعات وفقا لخبراء يمتلك صيام
خاصيه تمكنه من ابطاء انترنت المستخدم من
الجيل الثالث او الجيل الرابع لشبكات
الهاتف المحمول مع تخفيضه الى مستوى شبكه
الجيل الثاني وبالتالي يصبح
اكثر عرضه للتنصت سبق لموقع سيتيزن لاب
الكندي النشر تقريرا كشف مراسلات بين
ايران وشركات ايران سال وشركات الاجنبيه
ومنها شركه بروتي الروسيه طلب فيها مسؤول
من الشركه الايرانيه ترتيب وصول فريق
تدريب الى ايران كما استفسر المسؤول
الايراني عن السياسات الحاليه للسفر الى
روسيا وامكانيه القيام بمثل هذه الرحله
ايران انترناشونال قالت ان الشركتين
الايرانيتين همرول اي يو ال وايران سيل
ساهمتا في تطوير انظمه التجسس اثناء قمع
الانتفاضه الشعبيه مشيره الى ان الشركتين
تخططان للمشاركه في المؤتمر العالمي
للجوال في برشلونه للتعرف على احدث
التقنيات في هذا المجال وربما يتم
استخدامهما لتنفيذ مطالب مرشد ايران علي
النظام الايراني وفي اكثر من موجه احتجاج
عمل على قطع الانترنت وتقييده في وقت
تعاونت فيه شركه الهاتف المحمول
الايرانيتان بشكل وثيق مع المؤسسات
الامنيه لتوفير معلومات المستخدمين من اجل
مراقبتهم والقبض عليهم خاصه وان الشركتين
الخاصتين تنتميان لكيانات اقتصاديه تتبع
بشكل او باخر لمؤسسات خاضعه لخامنائي
وتوضح التقارير ان هذه المعلومات تتضمن
الموقع الجغرافي للاشخاص والعنوان والرمز
الوطني وسجل سجلات المكالمات وحتى السجلات
المتعلقه بانشطه الاشخاص على الانترنت
[موسيقى]